à Bué petit village au cœur du
sint-erroi il y a 34 vignerons dont
Florent et Clément Pinard les deux
frères ont pris la succession de leurs
parents Vincent et Cosette perpétuant
une transmission familiale qui s'étale
sur plusieurs
génération on pourrait dire qu'ils
portent bien leur nom mais cela ne
rendrait pas hommage à leur cuvés leur
vin rouge ou blanc qui s'inscrivent sur
les cartes des palaces et des plus beaux
restaurants là on est sur un terroir
très calcaire très crayeux on est sur un
un calcaire oxfordien c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a 165 millions d'années de de
formation géologique très peu de
profondeur de sol et on est vraiment sur
des roches voilà très dures et ce
calcaire va apporter des vins vraiment
sur la fraîcheur la minéralité et
beaucoup
d'élégance c'est un vrai travail de
famille nos parents sont participe
toujours à la vie de la de l'entreprise
bien sûr et puis voilà on remonte comme
ça de génération en génération et c'est
vrai que c'est un bonheur de travailler
en famille on se comprend beaucoup avec
Florent on a les mêmes opinions les
mêmes idées dans le vin donc forcément
ça ça matche quoi il y a cette fierté de
continuer ce que nos parents
grands-parents et cetera ont commencé on
le fait parce qu'on a peut-être toujours
vécu dedans mais on aime ça c'est un
métier qui est extrêmement complexe par
par le contact avec les gens par le fait
d'être dehors dans la vigne par être à
la cave par rencontrer vraiment des
choses tellement différentes c'est un
métier qui est
merveilleux les fermentations
alcooliques se terminent alors on
complète l'ensemble des contenants là on
est sur des demi muis ce sont des fus de
600 l en chaîne ce qui est le contenant
traditionnel de de senser et de pouilli
des appellations du centre
Loire dommage vous avez pas les parfums
mais les parfums sont magnifiques ça st
très très bon on s des souignons qui ont
une belle maturité donc plutôt des
parfums de poire de fruits à chair
blanche c'est vraiment très
agréable parfait mais alors avec le
Chavignol du sangcer rouge ou du sancer
blanc avant de répondre un peu
d'histoire le Chavignol et et les vin de
Sener c'est une histoire tout à fait
commune d'ailleurs la plupart des
familles faisaient des fromages de
chèvre et des vines SCERES et en fait
quand il y a eu la maladie du philoxéra
qui a complètement ravagé le vignooble
sanserroie pas que le sanserroi
d'ailleurs les les parcelles de vignes
ont été réquisitionné pour plutôt faire
des élevages de chèvres donc il y a eu
un vrai essort de la production de
fromage de chèvre au début du 20e siècle
l'un a donc remplacé l'autre pendant un
certain temps aujourd'hui le choix
cornélien n'est plus de mise là c'est
l'apéritif sans serroir par excellence
l'accord chavignolle sans ser tout va
bien on a choisi un une cuvée floresse
donc un un senser blanc sur le MiSim
2021 qui ira très bien avec la la
fraîcheur des des chavignoles plus
jeunes et puis le terroir chaîn marchand
sur un milzim 2009 donc un milzim avec
de la puissance de la densité qui ira
très bien avec un fromage encore plus
affiné et voilà on suit un petit peu la
courbe de l'évolution plus l'affinage
est prononcé et plus on va on va
préférer choisir des sensers des
sauvignons avec un peu plus d'âge parce
qu'il faut faut pas oublier que le
Sauvignon de ser c'est aussi des des
très très beaux vins de garde et tout
comme les chavignoles on a des affinages
qui sont qui sont merveilleux quoi avec
le
temps